oh hey Zack check out this vid man had  skip in five seconds whoa the sad even  for is this a yogurt commercial it's for  auto insurance why is it get in the car  he's getting in the car to go finance  Murrell de who's that that's the one  that's sleeping with Larry is that the  one with glasses  no that's Dante Gandhi that dog is  literally the cutest thing I've ever  seen  what horse though it's so cute no just  look at the dude Esmeralda ha ha ha  maybe it's an anti-smoking PSA it's this  trailer for a movie where did the  zombies come from is that the dude from  Friday Night Lights Wow looks  spectacular right - oh man bone X add  three inches to your penis today oh oh  ok here's the actual video I want to  show you  ah ha